el resurgimiento del coronavirus en
francia elevó los contagios a niveles
que no se habían alcanzado meses atrás
cuando el virus se instaló en el país el
fin de semana se alcanzó un récord de
27.000 nuevos casos el gobierno decretó
la alerta máxima en varias ciudades a
las que se sumaron montpellier y
toulouse
el primer ministro francés busca evitar
un nuevo confinamiento general sin
embargo no descarto confinamientos
locales ya que la situación en los
hospitales empeora su situación difícil
estamos en una situación muy difícil y
no sólo en francia la segunda ola es una
realidad y por eso de manera muy clara
imploro a todos que nos movilicemos para
enfrentar esta segunda ola de tus
profetas aceite de siembra kim quien
también busca evitar el confinamiento es
el primer ministro británico boris
johnson sin embargo el aumento de casos
y hospitalizaciones lo llevó a anunciar
un plan en tres niveles medio alto y muy
alto para enfrentar la segunda ola
de modo leve busca volver el nivel de
alerta medio cubrirá a la mayoría del
país e implicar a las medidas que rigen
actualmente eso incluye la regla de
reuniones de no más de seis personas y
el cierre de locales a las diez de la
noche en cya
el tercer nivel el más alto implica la
intervención en áreas locales y que
busca reducir las transmisiones entre
personas que viven en diferentes hogares
en españa los madrileños manifestaron en
contra de las imposiciones del gobierno
que decretó un nuevo cierre parcial
cientos de banderas ondearon en las
calles coincidiendo con la celebración
de la fiesta nacional con sede venido a
manifestar la vi porque estoy indignada
de la gestión que se está haciendo de la
pandemia la gestión no sólo de salud
sino también de konami a europa ya
superó los 7 millones de contagios y
españa es el país de la región con más
casos registrados